[Music]
my mom is the bomb we're more like best
friends we're just always goofing off we
love to hang out together like that's my
girl my mom as a person she's vivacious
she just steps into a room and the whole
world lights up she's one of the most
important people in my life my mom is
the strongest person I know she's a
single mom raised my sister and I and
has been there through a lot of hard
times for both my sister and I
especially recently I used to just be
next to her when she would be washing
the dishes and that would be like my
favorite time because I just get to talk
and tell her all the gossip in school
and talk about nothing really but she
was always there we just have a good
time together we're always laughing I
can't even remember a time where I've
actually gotten to an argument with her
or been mad at her we just don't we
don't have a relationship like that I
can tell her absolutely anything she has
been my best friend since day one we are
really close we talk every day if I
don't hear from my mom on a day or two
days it's like a weird thing
she always pushed me my hardest but she
also had such a soft spot for me my mom
called me one day when I was at work and
said don't freak out I'm sure it's no
big deal but I have a lump in my neck so
the first time was breast cancer the
second time was ovarian and third time
was skin so it's been a long road I
think being a single mom it's that much
harder to bring bad news to your
children and it kind of scared them for
the future there were no signs of
anything when she had the mammogram
something just didn't feel normal
she flew to Taiwan and we heard from our
mom and her dad over the telephone that
she had cervical cancer she couldn't
bring herself to say anything just
hi honey like what like no it's like
she's my mom
you know that cancer happens to any and
everybody but when it happens to you
it's like oh my god and then to happen
to my mother my best friends it was
something I wasn't ready for and I know
she wasn't ready for either don't really
remember how I felt I just remember
being kind of like what do we do now my
first reaction though was I'm going home
I need to drop everything and go help
her in her time of need
just watching her go through it was very
emotional because I felt like I couldn't
do anything for her everything happens
for a reason which is a big mantra in my
family I don't know how much you want me
to go into this I was only because I
just got diagnosed with breast cancer
[Music]
so definitely learned a lot from this
they don't know that I would have
handled all this as well if I hadn't had
her about my side for every appointment
every surgery every doctor's visit and
test result oh I wasn't sure if I was
gonna even like talk about myself today
can you roll with the punches my sister
my dad and I were all in the same room
when it happened it was actually more
peaceful than I thought it would be I
had 18 amazing years with my mom I feel
like sometimes when things go well and
something has gotta be like it for me
it's probably her so I just wanted her
to know that I'm with you I can't feel
the pain that you're going through but
I'm with you in June my mom will be
three years breast cancer free she's
stronger mentally now because of it and
physically my mom is doing really well
she's actually healthier now than she
was before
cancer know that you're not alone in
this process unfortunately there are a
lot of people who are battling with
cancer just know that you're stronger
than what you think you are
support sisters are everything you know
people think it's cliche to say like let
me know if I couldn't do anything
there's really nothing necessarily you
can do except to show your support and
ensure that you're there even for
something as simple as a phone call or
you know coffee just to let them know
that they have you know shoulder to lean
on is really helpful I want to say
something like easy like time will help
but I don't know if
has helped that much if someone's going
through this right now I hope they know
that the pain that they feel is it'll
come in waves you know and like you just
have to ride the wave sometimes I guess
mom I just want to say that I love you
and I'm proud of you the journey still
continues but you got this you are the
strongest most badass person and I'm so
proud to be your daughter thank you for
being everything you've taught me so
much about life and persevering and
especially now I don't know where I'd be
without you I would really want her to
know that I'm okay for anyone battling
cancer or for anyone going through this
journey with someone there are a lot of
resources out there annual walks dancing
events like dancing with the survivors
and then there's also like message
boards and stuff like that people you
can talk to when you feel like you don't
have the answers you feel like you're
just alone battling something that you
didn't ask for so there's always people
you can talk to there's always ways that
you can help others you just have to go
to google and search it out
you
[Music]